su médico puede realizar una biopsia
transtorácica con aguja o bethea para
diagnosticar enfermedades dentro o cerca
de sus pulmones los pulmones se
encuentran en la cavidad del pecho entre
la superficie de los pulmones y la pared
del pecho existen dos capas de tejido
que constituyen la pleura una de las
capas la pleura visceral se encuentra
adjunta al pulmón en sí mientras que la
otra capa la pleura parietal se
encuentra adjunta a la pared del pecho
una pequeña cantidad de líquido en el
espacio pleural que es el espacio entre
las dos capas permite que los pulmones
se expandan y contraigan suavemente con
cada respiración se puede ordenar una
biopsia transtorácica con aguja para
diagnosticar afecciones como el asma
el cáncer de pulmón
la neumonía y lesiones en el pecho
antes de su procedimiento es posible que
le administren medicamentos para
eliminar la tos su médico puede usar
diversas técnicas de diagnóstico por
imágenes como una tomografía
computarizada o un ultrasonido que le
ayudarán a ubicar con precisión el
objetivo de su biopsia y a guiar la
inserción de la aguja
se le limpiará la piel en el lugar por
donde se insertará la aguja justo encima
de una de sus costillas para ayudarlo a
relajarse es posible que la administra
en un sedante suave y anestesia local
para adormecer el área por lo general el
procedimiento dura menos de 30 minutos
para comenzar su médico puede hacer una
pequeña incisión en su piel por donde se
insertará la aguja luego mientras
aguanta la respiración y permanece lo
más quieto posible su médico le
insertará la aguja a través de su piel y
pared del pecho es posible que sienta
una presión y luego un repentino dolor
agudo cuando la aguja llegue a la
superficie de su pulmón su médico
obtendrá rápidamente la muestra de
líquido o tejido y retirará la aguja
luego se usará una radiografía de tórax
u otras técnicas de diagnóstico por
imágenes para asegurarse de que su
pulmón no haya colapsado el tiempo de
recuperación normalmente es muy corto
volverá a casa el mismo día del
procedimiento a menos que haya alguna
complicación